Das alleine war schon eine sensation vor einigen wochen wurde im sibirischen kammer frost ein
40.000 jahre altes fohlen gefunden und es ist auch ziemlich gut erhalten und jetzt das ein
forschungsteam will das pferd klonen wie das genau funktionieren soll und wie
realistisch es ist dass wir so
ausgestorbene arten wieder aufleben lassen können erfahrt ihr jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich ein sensationsfund ende august hatte das russische forschungsteam das fohlen der ausgestorbenen art aequo ihn nennen sie es
aufgespürt und zwar in einem 100 meter tiefen krater der auch als maul der hölle bekannt ist im nordosten zwischen darabos der tiger
ja und dieser per mappus hatte dafür gesorgt dass das fossil super konserviert wurde dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
simon
gregory der körper des tieres greene ohne
schäden erhalten sogar das fell ist noch vorhanden aber nicht nur das auch der schwanz die haut des tieres und die ufer sind noch gut
erhalten äußerst selten bei solch alten kunden denn das forschungsteam ist sich sicher der bund ist zwischen 30 und 40
tausend jahre alt das forschungsteam vermutet dass das tier zusammen todeszeitpunkt etwa zwei monate alt war schon früher gab es immer mal wieder
spektakuläre funde aus dieser region
beispielsweise die überreste eines höhlenlöwen mammuts und
wollnashörner die große hoffnung vieler forschungsteams solche
ausgestorbenen spezies wieder aufleben zu lassen genau das haben wir es wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus russland und südkorea auf den plan sie haben verkündet das fohlen schon bald klonen zu können in der zeitung sieht sein
wollen in der zeitung sie beginnt ein sagt einer der beteiligten
stammzellenforscher rosig waren wir werden versuchen aus entnommenen gewebeproben kulturen anzulegen sollte und dass bei diesem uralten pferd
gelingen könnten unsere methoden auch auf andere projekte
angewendet werden konkret plant das team ein modernes fährt als ersatzmutter für die geklonten eck wo es ines
embryonen einzusetzen voraussetzung dafür wäre lediglich eine einzige
rekonstruierte zelle des konservierten polens so die forscher und forscherinnen doch genau da dürfen nicht gerade einfach im gegenteil bisher sei es noch nie gelungen
eine zelle mit solch einem uralten erbgut zu gewinnen doch wann und seinen kollegen und kolleginnen sind
optimistisch und bezeichnen ihren ganzen plan als
machbar das hätten experimente mit eingefrorenen ausziehen gezeigt konkret setzen sie auf gut erhalten das muskelgewebe
um noch intakte zellen aufzuspüren doch wie
realistisch sind diese pläne wirklich interessanter da ganze sache ist die vorgeschichte von wo
sobald er betreibt eine art cologne fabrik in der jeden tag etwa
500 neue tiere produziert werden hier geht es um verstorbene haustiere meist und mit ihrer dna
schafft bank lohne mit denen er dann wiederum die trauernden besitzer glücklich macht und das ziemlich erfolgreich konkret
funktioniert das mit hilfe des
somatischen zellkern transfers ein verfahren bei dem die
hautzellen des tieres genutzt werden das geklont werden soll hier wird dann der kern entfernt und in eine eizelle ohne eigenen zellkern eingesetzt die
hundebesitzer kostet das einige tausend us-dollar hat sein wohl größter clou gelangen waren
2005 als es ihm gelang snooki zyklon snoopy steht für seo
national university papi und meint einen afghanischen wind und seine erbinformation
der ohren seines vaters endung knapp 1100 embryos wurden in die gebärmutter von
123 hündinnen eingesetzt und es gab tatsächlich zu drei schwangerschaften
snoopy ist der einzig überlebende ein wirklicher erfolg der 2006 von dem amerikanischen national human genome research
institute als solcher bestätigt wurde der weltweit erste geklonte hund wann galt seitdem als pionier der
stammzellenforschung doch dann ging es mit ihm bergab bis
2005 war er professor an der universität in tirol bis dann herauskam dass er riesige datenmengen gefälscht hatte
mittlerweile steht sein name für einen der größten forschung skandale dieser zeit konkret ging es um ein experiment aus
2004 hatte man behauptet erstmals stammzellen linien aus einem geklonten menschlichen
embryo entwickelt haben nach einigen angaben habe er diese dann auf einzelne patienten zugeschnitten
später kam allerdings heraus dass er einen seiner
mitarbeiterinnen benutzt hatte das hatte die wahl
2005 selbst zugegeben ein jahr später kam dann eine untersuchung heraus die seine gesamte stammzellforschung für gefälscht erklärte
nichtsdestotrotz wangs plan bezüglich des fohlens aus dem sibirischen permafrost ist klar und er ist tatsächlich nicht der einzige der dieses ziel nämlich
ausgestorbene tierarten wieder zum leben zu erwecken
verfolgt ja wir haben hier darüber bei pixum hier
schon mal berichtet es geht um mammuts mars wandert tauben und den magen brüter frosch alle längst
ausgestorben dennoch besteht die hoffnung dass sie demnächst vielleicht wieder auf der erde leben könnten das ist der plan der so genannten die extinction
bewegungen das sind diejenigen leute die sich um die wiederbelebung
ausgestorbener tierarten kümmern wie
beispielsweise auch der genetiker george church von der renommierten harvard university in boston er will ein embryo
entwickeln das halb elefant und halt wollhaarmammut ist und dass in naher zukunft
das hat der anfang letzten jahres auf einer wichtigen wissenschaftskonferenz in boston verkündet auch andere forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten schon jagt seit jahrzehnten daran längst
ausgestorbene tiere von den toten zu erwecken vor rund 14 jahren hat die zellkerne aus dem letzten exemplar der ausgestorbenen
pyrenäen steinberg entnommen und diese in ziegen eingesetzt und das ganze war wirklich
vielversprechend im sommer 2003 kam ein steinberg klein zur welt das allerdings nach wenigen minuten er steht die ganze idee
die heutzutage noch wie science fiction klingt ruft natürlich auch kritiker auf den plan sie werfen den beteiligten
forschungsteams vor sich wie gott auf zu spielen doch ist es auf der anderen seite nicht eine art korrektur werden wir menschen
ausgestorbene tiere zurück bringen deren ausrottung wir selbst zu verantworten haben
andere kritiker sprechen von frankenstein methoden und wieder andere fordern das investierte geld besser zu nutzen
um noch lebende arten zu schützen ja wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann abonniert doch klicks um natürlich nicht die
vergessen oder
werden sogar mitglied mit einem kleinen beitrag tut ihr gutes wir schalten damit nämlich immer mehr werbung vor den videos ab und ihr bekommt ein
paar spannende extras einfach hier unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den link in der video beschreibung und hier geht es weiter mit dass mamut
wiederbeleben doktor frankenstein wird realität dafür also hier klicken und über whatsapp
bekommt er die video links übrigens vor allen anderen vor mir dafür hier klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran